[Musique]
votre livre était pas de temps pour une
raison très simple c'est que ça raconte
à la fois votre parcours de femme votre
votre naissance à votre féminité et à
votre identité de femme ça raconte une
époque on est juste avant 68 et ça
raconte une espèce de folie douce entre
un garçon et une fille est donc vous
tombé raide dingue
l'un de l'autre godard et vous et il
vous explique comment
dans quel contexte se situer il vous dit
ceci je veux que vous sachiez exactement
où j'en suis entre nous par moments le
vouvoiement revenait le resterons nous
avions déjeuné ce vide est une jeune
femme balayé entre les tables le serveur
lisaient un quotidien derrière le bar
personne ne demandait de partir ont
semblé nous avoir oublié jean-luc en
profita pour m'expliquer de façon très
claire avec un minimum de mots qu'il
avait énormément aimé anna karina qu'il
avait beaucoup souffert quand elle
l'avait quittée mais que leur histoire
était fini depuis longtemps
il ajouta qu'il avait été pris de marina
vlady jusqu'au jour où il était venu me
voir à mon frein en tombant amoureux de
moins il avait cessé de l'aimer elle
avec lui il allait tourner mais digne on
essaye avec l'autre à partir de 8 ou
deux ou trois choses que je sais d'elle
c'est donc très simple je suis seul sans
aucune attache libre et vous moi a à
peine 19 ans non seulement j'étais on a
17 de plus
oui ce n'est pas grave qu'ait aucune
importance à l'époque quelqu'un m'avait
dit je pense toujours ça les gens que
j'aime mon âge et c'est toujours valable
donc jean luc avait 17 ans moi prendre
cette chance il s'est enquis ce que tu
racontes 19
il me fait du trait et donc n'ont jamais
personne c'était ici d un oral de
rattrapage foyen premier amant qui vont
tourner quand même dans les environs oui
c'est vrai j'ai oublié une fois de plus
et alors ce godard qui ont basculé il
est déjà dans 26 lesca note parce qu'il
ne servait pas pour l'histoire
la seconde d'arc que vous rencontrez
alors on le voit bien déjà dans une
maîtrise totale de son cinéma même s'il
est colérique sur sur les plateaux et si
peu engueulé même de mauvaise foi c'est
son équipe mais c'est aussi celui que
vous nous fait découvrir qu'on connaît
assez peu parce qu'il ya assez peu de
documents c'est quelqu'un qui est un
tout petit enfant quand il est dans
l'amour ou dans la relation amoureuse
c'est quelqu'un qui a le génie des
cadeaux qui fait des cadeaux il vous
offre un livre de grammaire chinoise qui
date du début du siècle
et à chaque fois il remet votre nom dans
dans les cadeaux qui vous fait c'est un
gauchiste pu réduire la chinoise c'est
pas pour rien il est en train de le
devenir est en train de le devenir il
est en train de d'allumer l'union
soviétique pour se rapprocher des dd
chinois et c'est aussi un conformiste
quand il va demander votre main à votre
grand père
le monument qu'est mauriac s'est il sait
aussi être parfaitement bourgeois dans
le comportement n'avait pas le choix
une fille cette époque là est mineur
seulement à 21 ans et françois mauriac
était notre tuteur à mon frère pierre
est à moi donc en gros pour avoir sa
fiancée il fallait pour que tout
simplement puisse coucher ensemble
tranquillement
comment nous souhaiter autant qu'on le
souhaitait il fallait en passer par le
mariage
la pie ix mais bon on passait par le
mariage tout de même et accessoirement
dans dans ce film où les où les couleurs
sont les couleurs primaires sont très
présentes et faustin des indes et des
caractéristiques du film que vous
tournez dans dans l'appartement du
huitième arrondissement qui est votre
appartement autrement dit vous venez de
sortir d'une nuit torride avec jean luc
godard et ensuite vous êtes sur le
plateau donc est-ce que ce cas pas une
difficulté de passer d'un rôle ride
c'est vous qui le dit sans détour de nos
deux ou trois parce que ça a pu être un
peu un peu torride
oui très amoureux disons alors que
comment fait-on pour passer de la
chambre à coucher au plateau de tournage
et bien s'adapte c'est à dire
moi j'ai absolument adoré cette vie là
justement où fiction réalité se
mélangent
d'ailleurs je comprends maintenant que
c'est que c'est exactement ce qu'il a
fait avec moi dans la chinoise
il a pris le personnage que j'étais dans
la vie l'étudiant à nanterre c'était mes
vêtements mes casquettes mes pulls même
ma bague et il l'a transformé en
étudiante maoïste que j'étais pas du
tout est donc finalement il m'a utilisé
pour mon plus grand bonheur
faire un film formidable et c'est la
réponse de la bergère à son berger plein
d'années après moi je les utilise lui
pour faire un film que j'estime ses
lapsus en plus vous avez fait des films
documentaires
un livre que j'espère bien et donc donc
me suis beaucoup inspiré du des couleurs
et du rythme des chinoises sur
l'écriture est sûre sur la technique
littéraire
comment est ce que vous avez à ce point
de souvenirs comment ça fait vous êtes
très mignon et les autres aussi parce
que comment pouvez vous imaginer que
j'ai une telle mémoire non mais
justement cet événement c'est la naïveté
de vous poser oui déphasé pour les
effectifs non non c'est impossible mais
tout du tout écrit selon j'écrivais un
journal j'ai inventé c'est à dire
reconstituer des choses et je me suis
aussi servi de la mémoire de mon frère
pierre de là mais palop la demande en
mariage je n'en n'ai aucun souvenir
et c'est mon frère qui ne la raconte est
aidé en lice est racontée par le frère
antoine gallimard aussi mon amie
nathalie et puis les journaux d'époque
et puis par exemple que ce truc infernal
qu'on a provoqué quand on a su qu'on
était mariée dans la presse ma mère
avait fait un dossier de presse que
j'avais donc j'ai remis le nez dedans et
la gérer et utiliser ces articles idiot
merci merci de cette honnêteté de
moments étonnants quand vous finissez
par par par dire à votre grand père que
vous connaissez cette ce devenant
gauchistes et votre grand père
10 à double le cinéaste ici devenir le
grand père de jean luc godard quelle
consécration est évidemment le soir elle
va raconter à godard ce qu'a dit le
grand père et godard répond tout de même
devenir le petit fils de françois
mauriac quelle consécration
oui parce que lui il faut toujours
qu'ils aient le dernier mot donc c'était
que ce soit bria qui reste sur un bon
mot il fallait clients face à un autre
mais voyez ça je l'avais complètement
oublié aussi c'est dans mon journal
donc je n'allais pas
[Musique]